it's more than a little bit it really is
the fact that you're there and i i truly
you know believe that laughter is the
best medicine and you are out there
as one of the the giants a giant
pharmacist of this medicine i love that
we give um let me so i hear okay i love
that you said that here's what i've been
telling myself and now i see it with the
crowds because i see you out there
working on your stuff
you know comics we go to the gym right
you know
laughter's the best medicine we've all
heard that howie
and people go well how can you still do
it with cancelled culture let's go i go
that's all [ __ ] if laughter is the
best medicine would you ever want your
who wants their medicine watered down
you want your medicine potent
name brand full
dose
and it's working well i agree
but it it works
um in front of the audience i do
personally have a fear
of getting canceled and you
you walk that edge even harder because
an insult could be taken out of
a context or even
not that that's something that you even
care about but even referring to
somebody as a different pro the things
that they're looking at now or the
things that you or i might have done 15
or 20 years ago a tweet a video
something a sketch we were in right it
could come up and then you're just
canceled do you not think about that or
you don't give a [ __ ] i do give a [ __ ]
because
not because i'm worried about getting
cancelled it's more because i don't like
to hurt people's feelings that eats at
me the roast master general says which
is interesting yes
when i hurt someone's feelings in a rare
occasion that it gets back to me
it eats at me and that's what keeps me
up because i really do try to find the
line but even as a single guy yeah you
know dating
you know you can't ask anyone out that's
over what do you mean women have to make
the first move they have to
guys are i can't i don't know how to do
it anymore
so a woman if a woman wants to go out
with you she has to tell me or she has
to flirt she has to tell me something
and it's it's really a problem it's
really hard and what about you
misreading uh what you think is uh
doesn't happen because i'm not doing it
i just can't it's just too scary i could
still have my swagger i can still
be charming i can still try to be funny
and try to get someone to like me just
like i always did since i'm like 13
but
as far as crossing the line to that
first kiss or like can i get your number
i do think it's a woman's world now and
by the way bumble is the most popular
dating site i'm not on it but women tell
me that's how they like to meet guys on
bumble women have to choose it's not a
it's not a democracy women it's women's
but i'm talking about a date it's just
like uh
you know without mentioning names there
are people that have gotten close to
being canceled
from what
i would consider a bad date right or a
mis
uh
calculation of what they thought was a
signal right which happens it's just two
people who don't really know each other
and you think that's what they meant on
another note just changing directions
fun talking about this stuff right it is
i i i love sitting down with you and
being able to air it out well i'm really
scared you know i'm scared because i
happen to be
on what is considered and i love my job
there at america's got talent but it's
you know it's a broadcast network and
it's ad supported
and so i am i feel like so [ __ ]
stifled all the time you know because
you're on social media and you're
popular on social media and that's where
most of this [ __ ] goes down as you know
if you're at uh a comedy club or you
know one of our pop-ups outside right
nobody gives a [ __ ] of what you say you
could say queen elizabeth is the biggest
[ __ ] in england and everyone will laugh
if you say that on social media you're
going to get fired it's not a good room
it's just not a good room so i stopped
putting comedy on my twitter i just
stopped i was like this isn't a good
crowd but you were doing comedy you were
doing roasts on instagram
that's a good crowd
that's fans reaching out going please
roast me it's my birthday i am in the
hospital i just had surgery please roast
me it's our anniversary let me have it
so that's a good crowd but for some
reason twitter not a good crowd
wow in the beginning you remember we'd
write a joke and you'd see you've got a
thousand retweets and this is such a
look what happened to gilbert
on twit on twitter and those were people
who were angry who don't follow him
right how can you get mad at a joke that
you're not at if i do a joke at the
comedy store and someone at the improv
gets offended what world are we in
anymore you know my little theory there
is that the company that fired him
you know wanted they were probably
paying too much money yeah he looked for
an excuse to get rid of him and they
have the exact same character that
sounds exactly like gilbert still and
that's probably somebody just working
for scale don't you think i got the call
right when gilbert gilbert's a good pal
of mine i just spent days with him and
his family in florida on the beach isn't
he great i love gilbert with all my
heart and i love his his wife and kids
um
i got an email i got an audition to
audition for that [ __ ] duck
that he got fired for and i thank you
for the email you sent gilbert even of
course i go gilbert i'm gonna take your
job of course i didn't even audition but
it just made me crazy what hypocrites
they were they're going back to another
rose comic
for an audition after what they just
publicly hung him out to they made him
apologize
to get paid and then still fired him
it's amazing it makes me crazy but
that's
that's scary from the time that i
started you know the um the safety net
was a joke
it's a joke like even if you weren't in
this business if you said something and
somebody turned around and they were
offended by what you said or you might
be getting in trouble the the safety net
was i was just joking i was joking and
if you if if they believe that it was
just a joke it was okay but now they
take the joke
as hard as they take a direct bullet to
the
between the eyes and that's not what
it's meant to do it's meant to diffuse
those bombs it's meant to
take the pain out of life and
it's like that's not funny you can't
joke about that of course you can well
there's never too soon
there's never but not in the world of
comedy in you know amongst us
and there's nothing that's off
limits there really isn't there is to
the public to the general public but
really real comedy comes out of tragedy
and darkness
when
when 9 11 happened i remember being in
new york and it was a big thing that
and dave chappelle and his wife and baby
evacuated the soho grand to my apartment
in the village
and we were very distraught like what
are we gonna do is comedy over within 24
hours we were like do we need to cancel
the you hefner roast and i called my
manager at the time bernie brillstein a
comedy legend who'd seen it all
i thought
i said bernie like how do you what do
you think's gonna happen
he's like i don't know kid
i don't know
and when the old guys don't know what
the [ __ ] going on i start to go wow
we're in new unchartered territory here
and of course new york's resilient the
world's resilient and we all started
joking within a week but and by the way
there's a great documentary on vice
right now um called
too soon comedy after 9 11. i got to
check that out you'll love it it's all
about that time but gilbert did the did
the joke at the friars club right you
know we did the hugh hefner roast and
and i was a producer on that show so i
had to write a letter to the friars club
to half
and to comedy central saying
um
you know we wanted they wanted to pull
the show no one wanted to fly in from la
the the venue needed to know what we
were doing
and uh was this appropriate and we were
supposed to have an after party and i
said let's take the after party make it
a fundraiser for the twin towers fund
let's put on tuxedos go to the hilton
and do the show
and
if you don't do the show
the terrorists win
and that was not a cliche back then it
really meant something like
you were the first person to say that i
felt
i felt like that was the first event
that was like a real
because half hugh hefner everything the
terrorists could hate about america free
speech sex you know hef
you know maybe that was the epitome of
the epitome of all that i don't know if
the excess is the right word but america
freedom yes
and
and it wound up being a cathartic
fundraiser for something that was
important to us so i think comedy
besides just making us feel good it can
actually like do good in the world
[Music]